OK, this is something really special for everybody
today, over the last 24 hours, Fox News has
become a nexus, an epicenter almost like a
central clearinghouse of election disinformation.
And what makes it all the funnier is that
on one hand, Donald Trump is furious with
Fox News because their so-called news side
admits and accepts that Joe Biden won the
election.
Donald Trump is mad at Fox News for calling
Arizona for Joe Biden.
So as I told you yesterday, Trump, instead
of treating Fox News content, has been tweeting
a lot of Newsmax content, which is sort of
like a low rent Fox News.
On the other hand, if you tune into the nighttime
Fox News programs, the so-called opinion shows,
although, you know, the difference between
Fox News and opinion at this point is pretty
blurry.
The nighttime shows on Fox continue to pretend,
as a matter of fact, that this election was
stolen by Joe Biden.
They are bringing on every last grifter that
they can find.
And we're going to look at some examples and
what the the framing I want you to keep in
mind as you watch this is.
When people in other countries see this, they
think we're out of our minds, OK, this is
crazy that this is going on on one of the
three major cable networks in the United States.
And I am aware that watching this stuff is
not great for your brain.
And to make a really serious point, I'm going
to play short clips because this stuff is
crazy and it's really bad for you.
But remember, many Americans get their news
exclusively from Fox News.
They see this and they see no alternative
to it was stolen and they think it's serious.
So let's start with Donald Trump's press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany.
Almost a meme at this point, holding up pieces
of paper.
We don't know what the hell they are as proof
of fraud.
DeJohn, we keep hearing the drumbeat of where
is the evidence right here, Sean.
Two hundred thirty four pages of sworn affidavit
are a defiant and principled Kayleigh McEnany
holds up a ream area of paper.
Here is Republican Congressman Matt Gaits,
recently recovered from Coronavirus.
He's the guy who laughed off Coronavirus by
wearing a gas mask on the House floor back
in might have been March or something like
that.
He says he has sources, guys, and the sources
are telling him really, really bad things.
Well, in Washington, it is even worse than
your reporting.
My sources are telling me that part of the
Biden transition plan would be making permanent
these coronavirus changes to the voting process.
Now, I have to tell you, I actually hope Matt
Gates is is correct.
Matt Gates is saying, oh, no, Joe Biden might
try to make it easier to vote by mail forever,
not just when there is a pandemic.
I hope Biden does do that.
What this election has proven is when you
expand vote by mail, it doesn't cause fraud.
It leads to voting.
That's what happens when you expand vote by
mail.
We should have expanded vote by mail forever
as well as expanded early voting.
I hope Matt Gates is right in what he's saying.
Here's Sean Hannity wrapping up about four
to five different conspiracy theories into
a pretzel and claiming they all prove that,
of course, this election was stolen from Joe
Biden of lies and conspiracy theories.
The rush, a hoax, Hillary's dirty dossier,
FISA abuse, lying to a FISA court, spying
on a presidential candidate and a president.
Fake Paul's fake news, fake everything.
And then here is Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
showing up to talk about this election as
if it's not over.
And it's as if Donald Trump might still win.
Proud of the work that the entire team that
the president has had four by four years has
accomplished above.
We'll have more time to continue to work to
keep Americans safe.
Hopefully we'll have more time to keep Americans
safe.
Trump lost, dude, what are you talking about?
And of course, Mike Pompeo also made a statement
to the press yesterday that there will be
a smooth transition into a second Trump administration.
We covered that early.
We don't know if Mike if Mike Pompeo really
believes this stuff or if he feels obligated
to say this stuff, we don't know it's bad
either way.
And then here's RNC Chairwoman Ronna McDaniel
claiming that the media have stolen the truth
by not reporting on their completely baseless
voter fraud claims.
And the media right now, by refusing to report
on this, is stealing our faith in the election
process.
Tell the story.
Talk about the people who are being disenfranchized.
People across this country deserve to have
election integrity of faith in our election
system and believe that there is election
integrity.
And that's why the RNC is going to pursue
this to the very end.
We can never let this happen again.
And lastly, Ted Cruz was on and he actually
Ted Cruz hilariously sort of stumbled on to
the truth about this situation.
Take a listen.
One of the frustrating things as a citizen,
you see all these tweets going back and forth.
You see allegations of this happen that happens.
It's hard to know.
It's hard for anyone to know.
All right.
Is this true?
What's true?
The only way to know is we have a legal process.
We have state courts.
We have federal courts that can hear legal
claims.
And right now, it is incumbent on the Trump
campaign's lawyers to go in and prove their
case in court, to lay out evidence, to lay
out evidence of illegally cast votes, to lay
out evidence of what was done right, what
was done wrong.
And when the process is over, we're going
to know the result.
But we need to let the process play out.
And much of the mainstream media doesn't want
to let us do that.
So Ted Cruz is actually hear me out.
OK, Ted Cruz is actually right.
There is a process for adjudicating these
claims.
And step one of the processes, you have to
present evidence to courts.
Where Ted Cruz is wrong is that the media
doesn't want that to happen.
The reality is courts keep looking at the
claims of fraud and they're finding them completely
without merit.
So the process doesn't continue.
The media is not stopping the process.
The media is asking questions like, do you
have specific evidence of illegal or fraudulent
votes?
And when that question was put to, for example,
Kayleigh McEnany two days ago, RNC Chairwoman
Ronna McDaniel, two days ago, they said a
lot, but they didn't say, yes, we have actual
evidence of specific illegal or fraudulent
votes.
And that's why this isn't moving forward in
courts.
It's not because the media is interfering,
but the complaints being brought to court
are being found to lack merit.
And so they aren't going forward.
But again, this is how Fox News creates an
alternate reality.
You tell your audience everybody else is lying
to you.
Everybody else is biased to the left to encourage
people to discount or even ideally not watch
anything other than Fox News.
You feel the Fox News evening echo chamber
with Laura Ingram had a so-called witness
last night who refused to be identified.
It was like a blacked out shadow beyond parody
after they spent four years saying any anonymous
source isn't OK.
They're putting up witnesses that are blacked
out in shadow.
They're making claims that the media don't
allow this to move forward.
And if you only get your news from Fox News,
you end up believing this stuff.
I've used the term mind virus several times
lately.
Trump ism is a mind virus.
The Fox News narrative, if it infects you,
is also a mind virus.
And we we can't just write them off because
they vote.
I get it.
The instinct is to laugh it off and you move
on.
But we can't because they do vote.